this isn't this isn't a happy aaron
rodgers topic this goes back to the scab
that was created the first night of the
draft when the packers not only failed
to give him a receiver either that night
or any of the other rounds of the draft
but trade it up
to get a quarterback who ostensibly will
replace aaron rodgers at some point
during the four base years of jordan
love's rookie contract and we've we've
sensed that we felt that aaron rodgers
has been as diplomatic as he possibly
can be about it but you don't trade up
and draft a guy
to play quarterback when you have a team
that was one game away from the super
bowl
if you're not thinking
this guy is a major potential force in
our not too distant future so
that all became relevant again on sunday
because pakistan i mean seriously just
say that again out loud like it doesn't
even sound right when you say it i just
i'm sorry to cut you off but because
because they're on the brink of the
super bowl right and instead of getting
the pieces they need to take the next
step
they they consciously draft a guy select
let's select a guy that can replace the
mvp of our team that makes no sense and
i'm you know just spitballing here mike
two guys that like football can you even
think of a scenario that's remotely
like similar in the history of the nfl
where uh all-time great questions goes
to the championship game
and then has this has this sort of issue
i guess there's tom brady and is that
about it or
no but been a first-rounder a
first-round rounder right that's what i
meant to you're right right
the closest the closest parallel
is when the packers drafted aaron
rodgers when brett favre was a starter
but that was 2005
right and they weren't good remember
what the packers pay pete what did the
what did the packers do in 2005 i know i
remember okay 2005 was a bad year i
can't remember what they did in 2004. i
think they lost 2004 they how can i
forget this it was the randy moss
mooning the fans game they lost wild
card 10-6 lost at home to the vikings in
the wild card round right that next
draft is when they took aaron rodgers in
the 20s
but
but here's the thing it's different
brett favre had been talking about
retiring right for three years they
needed to be ready for brett at any
given moment saying i'm out right and
and they didn't trade up in the first
round right it was it was a guy who very
well could have been the first overall
pick that year who fell into their lap
so it was very very different it's
similar but it's very different i think
that difference isn't lost on aaron
rodgers so you're right here we are 13-3
one step away
and we have clear needs to make that
next step so what do we do we invest the
first round pick second round pick third
round pick and fourth round pick because
the fourth round pick was used to trade
up in round one your first four draft
picks are all invested in this future
that is going to be premised on a 49ers
style running attack because matt
lafleur's big takeaway from getting his
butt kicked by the 49ers in the nfc
championship game was if you can't beat
him join him that's my read on it
i i think gets there's part of it you're
right he's talking about and i guess
they think okay
what aaron rodgers he's gotten us this
far without great help around him he can
do it again so let's maybe improve the
other parts of our team i i get that but
you know also there was defensive issues
in that game too as we've talked about
so it is a very weird scenario it really
is and rogers yeah i mean hey listen the
thing i came away from in that game is
they're not like just one player away or
anything like that either you know there
there's a there was a significant
difference between them
and the san francisco 49ers and as we
know the 49ers there was a difference
between them and the kansas city chiefs
so you know you sit there and you go oh
i feel all warm and cozy and right you
know yeah we got to the final four
there's a big difference between the
team that wins the super bowl and the
teams that lost in the final four you
know there there is a i think a
significant
talent level pieces on team missing
things like that and i think green bay
showed that to where yeah green bay i'm
not sitting here going this was like a
horrible draft and free agency but to me
it was it was like we're building for
something three years down the road and
i want to go
screw the road down there the road is
here right now and you're damn good and
you need a few pieces to help your
quarterback get over the edge and play
good if you're getting a shootout with
the 49ers again in the playoffs you
can't just go oh we're going to try to
get in the defensive struggle how about
you get some weapons and try to get in
the shootout so uh there's been yes it
was a debacle of an off season to me
from the packers free agency in the
draft and then now they don't have devin
functions because he opted out too mike
but remember after the draft those first
couple of rounds
mark murphy the ceo of the team it was
either him or it was the gm brian gouda
kunst made the comment that that matt
laflore wants
everything to flow through the running
game and and you look at what the 49ers
are doing and remember mike lafleur
is on kyle shanahan's staff with the
49ers and and and i i just think with
that running game remember that was the
bob greasy game for jimmy garoppolo
where he threw the ball like five times
and it was just run the ball run the
ball run the ball where he mustered had
a career day and i think maybe a little
shell shocked by that was matt lafleur
recognizing having a high-end passing
game isn't going to make a difference
for you if your defense can't get off
the field if you're if the other team is
controlling the clock i mean we need to
be ready to do the same thing we need to
be ready to play the same way so that's
why i think
the the the at least the the seed yeah
okay what became their draft strategy
right emerged that they want to be like
the 49ers that that's the key to having
a great team and it was proven out by
the way the 49ers played last year well
you don't need a gunslinger at
quarterback you just need a great
offensive design and a great running
game that works against denny d then why
trade up and get the quarterback though
you know what i mean that's why i would
just throw that right it almost doesn't
make sense you know i i because you're
going to need it we're going to build a
running team why do we have to trade up
for a quarterback for three years from
now i'm just throwing it out there i
know it's it's well no no hey because
this quarterback's going to become the
centerpiece for this run-based attack
right i i guess so whenever they unleash
it in 2022 or whenever
anyway that's the setup it is and it is
and and i'm just saying that's the setup
for what matt lafleur said yesterday
right it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense as you and i will agree right and
and when you consider all of that
and you compare it to what matt lafleur
said yesterday it makes even less sense
here's matt lafleur meeting with the
media talking about the future of oh
aaron rodgers in green bay
right now most importantly aaron's our
quarterback and i see him here for a
really long time and however long that
is
i don't think anybody knows nothing's
guaranteed in this league
but i feel
so lucky to be able to work with him on
a daily basis and uh you know i don't
see that changing for a really long time
okay um look if
and and a lot of times coaches find
themselves in a spot where they can't
come out and say
what they really believe right because
then it creates an issue
that grows and grows and then aaron's
going to react i mean if he'd have said
well you know what we we all see the
handwriting on the wall we we traded up
in round one to draft a quarterback
aaron's going to be here two more years
tops we all know that we're all grown
ups we get that if he says something
like that then it blows up right it
blows up in a bad way and it's a mess
that that he's gonna have to clean up
and aaron's gonna have to clean up even
though it it would be accurate and
realistic so
i'm not you know look hey
the entire sport of football is premised
on deception and the deception happens
in plenty of different forms and
fashions and in a situation like that i
can understand why matt lafleur said
what he said what else is he going to
say chris no well
yeah aaron rodgers getting traded after
the 2021 season well i mean i mean
you're right
there's nothing he can really say at
this point you know certainly uh again
what i'll go back to is you know
lafleur's a pretty good running
you know offensive mind running game
offensive mind certainly i mean we've
seen that the titans two years ago when
he was the offensive coordinator there
and then you know of course last year
with green bay the issue in his offense
has been the pass game you know the pass
game is where i look at it and go it
needs more imagination they need to do
more i've heard him say that and
recognize that this off season more
aggressive plays down the field all of
those things you know that to me was
more of a weakness to their team than
the run game so i just feel like that's
where they should have capitalized and
here's my big thing too mike and i don't
know this
but
i you know i've been around matt lafleur
a number of times in my life because he
did work for kyle shanahan and that and
all that i question
and i think this is a legitimate
question did matt lefour really want
this did he want this did he really want
to stir this pot and deal with this my
guess in knowing the human being
is that he did not want to stir the pot
or be put in this position this is not
easy for a young head coach second year
you know now he's got to deal with this
i mean last year he had to deal with
rogers and lefleur and the audible thing
now he's got to deal with whoa i got to
replace aaron rodgers he's like what the
hell can i get an easy off season here
in green bay so i do question that too
that if this was just
a a a a organizational decision where
they kind of just went over matt lafleur
and said hey you don't have the the
jurisdiction on the draft and free
agency like that and we're going to do
what we think is best and i'm not so
sure that's not the case
a year ago at this time you and i had
concerns about what matt lafleur was
going to do as the head coach of the
team especially because he's walking
into a situation with an aaron rodgers
who
who could be a handful for a head coach
who doesn't know how to handle him and
it all worked out incredibly well they
went 13-3 matt lafleur made his bones he
proved that he can get it done right and
his reward his reward was
hey matt you did so well with the
potential dysfunction in 2019 right
we're gonna crank it all the way up to
15
this year and give you a first round
quarterback that we traded up to get
good luck with all that maybe you can go
14 and 2. i'd be pissed if i was matt
lafleur and look again these are things
that no one is ever going to come out
and say at least not until there's a
tyler dunn bleacher report article a few
years from now that goes all the way
down the rabbit hole and tells us
exactly what happened but i feel like
the guy at the top of the pyramid mark
murphy the ceo of the team who is a lot
more involved in football now than he
ever used to be when it was ted thompson
to mike mccarthy mark murphy just signed
the checks and stayed out of the way now
he's involved and i think back to the
tyler dunn article from last year
when mar mark murphy in the aftermath of
that entire mess with the the issues
between mccarthy and rogers and all of
the stuff that they denied and some of
the stuff they didn't deny i feel like
murphy liked that i feel like murphy
thought you know what this is gonna be
the red-hot poker that the team needs
this year
and since it worked last year
i can't help but want you to think he's
going to the weather in some way this is
the this is the 2020 version of the red
hot poker right
let's let's let's give aaron rodgers
every reason to be upset and motivated
and then it'll be a good problem if he
gives us two more years as we see right
the early signs of slippage which you
saw definitely president of the aaron
rodgers fan club you saw it if you saw
it they saw it this is the way to get
him to keep sprinting for the carrot
over the next two seasons and then if he
has two great seasons we dump him onto
some unsuspecting schmuck out there who
thinks they're getting aaron rodgers
this high at the height of his powers
and they give up way too much and then
they realize oh god that's it the treads
off the tire he's done well yeah i mean
you know that that could be the case i'm
not going to deny any of that i mean you
know that that's that's a theoretic
theoretically makes sense i get it
okay but i also all right so
theoretically what if he goes out there
and just lights the world on fire the
next two years what if this year he's in
the mvb conversation the next year good
okay
well they're going to trade them they're
going to trade sell high oh yes that's
my point i know that's my point he plays
at a higher level this year and next
year because he's upset i get to i get
you but it's like okay he hey he's still
the mvp of your team and what if you go
to the nfc championship game like i know
what you're saying but i'm just giving
you a little bit of like a vice versa to
where oh now you're gonna trade the best
player in your team and just say walk
out the door hey guys we've gone to the
nfc championship game like two out of
three years and aaron rodgers been on
fire we're gonna get rid of them and go
with this unproven guy right now we're
kind of in the window they drafted him i
know they've already noticed they've
already shown us what they're gonna do
well i wouldn't be surprised when they
do it i know well you're right it just
but it to me that would be
just just stupid for lack of a better
way oh and you know i think there's a
very real case in which we're seeing
quarterbacks they don't fall off much in
their mid-30s to where yeah it was 26
and four last year and there was a hair
slippage but when we're talking about
hair slippage for what i think is the
greatest quarterback i've ever seen in
my life we're talking about he went from
the number one to the number three
quarterback in football behind two
freaks of nature in my homes and russell
wilson so you know what i would just say
is green bay better be worried or mark
murphy better you worry that hot poker
you're talking about that you know aaron
quick hands grabs that poker and
reverses it and goes oh mark it's right
on your pants now what do you got to say
about that and that's what i'd be
worried about if i'm a green bay or in
their organization
i think back to 2008 they went to the
nfc championship game they took the
giants to overtime and but for a
misguided throw by brett favre and we've
all seen that still frame remember that
from 12 years ago with three eyes open i
think the still frame was a little
misleading but but still the point was
brett favre does a brett favre thing and
throws an interception in overtime in
the nfc championship game and they went
to him just a few weeks later and said
we got to know right now what you're
doing for 2008 knowing that if they
pressed him for a decision in february
his answer would be i'm retiring so they
managed to get rid of him they went
through that ugliness in training camp
when he decided he wanted to come back
and then what happened three seasons
later
they were holding a trophy
they were holding the trophy with aaron
rodgers at quarterback so i i just yeah
again all this stuff we're talking about
yes it seems
incomprehensible that that they would
move on from aaron rodgers after the
2021 season
but they've already done the thing
that makes us look at it and say that's
where it's going otherwise what have you
done i mean it's you don't you do it
jimmy garoppolo second round quarterback
if if it's not a guy that you're
eventually going to make they probably
could have got him in the second round
you don't trade up in round one yeah for
a guy that you just keep for four years
and then flip to someone else for a
second round pick i agree with that
you're right it puts more pressure on
the situation because if we're sitting
there and it's jordan love year three
and he's still backing up aaron rodgers
that's where the poker will be reversed
around and everyone's going to be going
why the hell did we draft this guy what
are we doing rogers is still playing
he's still our quarterback blah blah
blah blah so you're right and mike if it
goes the other way around where aaron
rodgers leaves town in a year or two
whatever
let's just make sure we're fair to green
bay if they end up going to the super
bowl with jordan love we'll be here the
first ones to kiss your butt mark murphy
and and uh everybody else in the green
bay organization
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports